chers amis je ne sais pas ce que vous en
pensez mais pour ma part je trouve que
ces universités d'entrée elles ont une
saveur un petit peu particulière les
lieux restent les mêmes on est à Guidel
depuis 10 ans les visages
on les revoit chaque année quoi que il y
en a toujours de nouveau et je tiens à
saluer le visage d'une jeune démocrate
qui a fait un voyage de très loin qui
est Hélène polozzek conseillère
départemental de Mayotte qui a
certainement parmi les jeunes fait le
plus long voyage pour être parmi nous
[Applaudissements]
et évidemment comme chaque année les
débats sont toujours d'aussi bonne
qualité mais je disais que ces
universités ces universités de rentrée
ont une saveur particulière et elles
sont un petit peu émouvantes après une
année comme celle que nous venons de
vivre une année charnière dans le site
électoral habituel de la Cinquième
République une année de présidentielle
et une année de législative
et c'est un petit peu émouvant parce que
déjà nous avons vécu des combats rudes
éprouvant et j'ai une pensée pour toi
Patrick et pour tous les pour tous nos
députés de la précédentement nature qui
sont allés au combat et qui sont tombés
les armes à la main le 20 juin et vous
êtes toujours là et c'est une vraie
fierté pour nous de vous avoir
[Applaudissements]
émouvant également car on a réussi en
2022 à conforter notre place de second
pilier de la majorité présidentielle et
ça c'est particulièrement important et
grâce à notre groupe parlementaire notre
influence va pouvoir continuer de se
diffuser dans le paysage politique
encore pour 5 ans et chez les jeunes
démocrates je tiens à le souligner on se
le disait avec Sarah hier il y a 5 ans
on avait une jeune démocrate qui
rentrait à l'Assemblée c'était elle 5
ans après on en a une autre c'est Louise
Morel c'est notre grande fierté chez les
jeunes notre bureau national on a poussé
une à l'Assemblée on a une porte-parole
[Applaudissements]
alors si nous n'étions pas au Mouvement
Démocrate on se contenterait d'en tirer
des motifs de satisfaction
mais je vous propose qu'on en tire
quelques motifs de résolution et qu'on
souligne notre responsabilité
particulière notre responsabilité tout
d'abord c'est que nous sommes les
porteurs d'un engagement d'un engagement
de longue haleine autour de François
Bayrou pour c'est nous qui avons creusé
le sillon finalement de ce bloc central
qui gouverne le pays aujourd'hui c'est
nous le canal historique de du
dépassement politique et ça ça nous
confère des responsabilités
particulières c'est à nous d'être la
boussole pour les cinq années prochaines
on a des responsabilités aussi car nous
sommes les héritiers d'un courant de
pensée philosophique et politique
profondément ancré dans dans l'histoire
du pays et dans l'histoire de la
Cinquième République
notre voyage attendu vous l'avez dit
président et vous l'avez dit en
ouverture on n'a pas le droit de laisser
des idées en déshérence et nous les
jeunes démocrates
nous voulons contribuer à cette
entreprise qui attend le mouvement
dire ce que nous sommes nous permettra
finalement de porter le projet
et de porter la voix qui est attendue
par notre famille politique les Jeunes
Démocrates nous disons que nous sommes
des humanistes et face au péril qui
pèsent sur les démocraties libérales
c'est essentiel de le redire nous sommes
des écologistes par parce qu'il n'y a
pas de planètes B et parce que chaque
jour l'urgence climatique et
environnementale se fait plus durement
sentir et enfin nous sommes des
Européens et quand on voit l'invasion
russe et les menaces qui passent sur la
construction européenne depuis la
Seconde Guerre mondiale c'est plus que
jamais essentiel voilà ce que j'avais à
vous partager merci à tous et à l'année
prochaine cher mode je t'invite à me
rejoindre